suppose if i'm in the dhawa booth and a
person is interacting with me
after the interaction the self analysis
that i would be doing is one of the most
precious time in dawa because i may be
thinking at that time
you know what i should have smiled more
at that person i should not have
interrupted the person as much as i did
maybe this reference is this analogy i
should have brought maybe i should not
have you know overwhelmed the person
with too much knowledge so that self
analysis can only happen when you're in
the field
not when you're behind the computer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to the realist podcast
in the dunya the three muslims podcast
today we are joined with two very
special guests on hill's mini bananas
throw those bad boys up again man let
the audience see
many bananas my friends who's a real
special guest bro
and the real special guest for today is
all the viewers with the greeting of
peace the greeting of assalamualaikum
the greeting that was there
uh for all the messengers and prophets
so i'm from chicago originally from
india india hyderabad do you guys know
heather about this um yeah my roommate
uh or my old roommate was hyderabadi
it's like the mid-southern part of india
yep my in-laws are from pakistan so i
have been more time to pakistan than to
india
all right
so i came here to chicago with my
parents and did my education here
then went to medical school did some
medicine
and then i realized you know what
i have been watching sheikh ahmadis
videos dr zakir naik's videos and dr
mirali's videos and i got inspired that
yes as being in the field of medicine i
can touch like perhaps this many people
but if i want to do the
the way
the message the vision if i want to
carry on of the messengers and the
prophets
i better actually reach out to them with
the message of islam
letting them know what is the guidance
what is the purpose of life who is the
creator who they should worship
so that was my
motivation of me to join dawa and
i manage a organization called gain
peace
so we are part of the islamic circle of
north america
so on behalf of gay and peace we have
new muslims that we take care of
mentorship and follow-up
classes
social activities educational activities
uh second thing that we do is we have
many open houses we package the message
of islam and reach out to the
non-muslims out there
open houses and dawa booths and radio
and tv ads
television ad social media
and lastly we want to empower our own
muslims
and remind them
that it's an obligation it's a necessity
that all of us we should convey the
message of islam that's where i stand
brothers
so i'm just curious what medical school
did you go to
i went to the caribbeans
and you were practicing for how long
uh two years up there and two years in
chicago
okay okay so was it an easy decision at
least with your family when you decided
that you want to take over dawa because
i can understand being from the south
asian community that when you
finally become a doctor which is a very
prestigious thing and you want to do
something else even if we're from muslim
families they don't always understand
the depth of what we want to do with the
dawah
it was i mean obviously it's not a easy
decision uh
at one point i was the only person in
the whole world perhaps
you know especially in my family who
were opposing to my decision
but then i realized you know i have one
life to live
uh i have obeyed my parents became a
doctor
and i can still continue that
but uh if i want to have impact
in the world if i want to
if i want to uh provide some solutions
for humanity's problems when it comes to
so many things going on i better do
something which is going to
which is going to align with the passion
which i had which is to share the
message
so it's never an easy decision however
what happened now is
after now people seeing the outcome the
benefits
of me entering full time into dhawa
almost every person alhamdulillah now
they are supporting me they are doing
dua for me
and i hope and pray that may allah
accept it from me and from all of us
so with da'wah where would you say it
started with you right who did he reach
out to how did he give dawah in the
beginning and how was that transformed
over time
so way back i used to watch uh many
videos of sheikh ahmadi dat so one of my
practices at that time and i'm going to
recommend this to every single youth
is that try to take notes
don't just passively watch the video but
also take the notes so i still have my
notes way back from that time and i
still benefit from it
so after taking the notes and compiling
the notes i started to
reach out to the msas
letting them know you know what let's do
dawah on the platform of msas and we had
many dawa trainings when i was using the
same notes which i was compiling
so that's how it got started and then
obviously we made a group
within ikna islamic circle of north
america
then we opened up hawaii islam and gain
peace
and
i would say the rest is history in one
way
so
each single one of us inshallah we can
have a humongous impact if we focus on
something
because if we have our hands on too many
places you know we are not able to have
that much impact compared to just razor
focus razor sharp focus on one thing
become a specialist
yes you can do many things but at least
be a specialist in one thing
you should be the go-to person in some
field within islam within dhawa
that's when you can have the greatest
impact to the muslim community
non-muslim community especially the
youth
you know that's how you can leave a
legacy
so
that would be my advice inshallah that i
followed based upon what shah madida dr
zakir naik were doing focus on one thing
and become a specialist in it
so so what would you say your specialty
is in islam
well within islam i would say i mean i'm
i don't call myself as a specialist i
would say i'm a student of uh you know
islam student of dawa
so i would say my passion lies within
dawah so
alhamdulillah whatever knowledge that
allah has given me when it comes to
dawah i would say that would be my focus
in life
rasha allah reward you for that
i mean i mean
so so the way so the way it got started
is that when i was in school
i used to be mostly in my room you know
just
less like any youth that as you see
nowadays
but my parents they were really
religious mashallah they used to
watch
they used to bring this uh tapes and
they used to watch islamic scholars
in the in the living room
and they used to always tell me you know
sabil come out and watch yes you may
have homework and all the things come
out and watch sometimes i used to
sometimes i was busy with whatever right
one day they said you know there is a
scholar a tape that we brought i want
you to come and watch us so the parents
told me they said doesn't matter if you
have the final exam tomorrow this is so
important for you
i said okay fine mummy baba
so i came out and i watched
and that was
the breaking point in my life
when i saw the person in the video
with confidence with the references in
comparative religion
you know
explaining the
faith of islam responding to the
questions
with confidence you know width of such
firmness
i felt really proud this is what islam
is
and that person on the video who do you
think it was
definitely ahmedita
there you go
no other choice man yes
alhamdulillah and i have the good
fortune of meeting him
masha'allah alhamdulillah
he used to come to chicago with
my teacher used to call him here for
debates and lectures and whatnot so i
studied under him when he used to come
to chicago alhamdulillah
i got a book from him he wrote a few in
many books actually a compilation of his
books it's called the choice
your brother's aware of that
he used to write many many small
booklets on different topics
and he used to distribute it all over
the world for free
and i received my package and then he
compiled all of them together into one
book called the choice
so that i received from him and that is
still my go-to book sometimes
man so
i was gonna ask prior and i'm gonna ask
this again uh just to get this straight
you're not practicing medicine anymore
i have let's just say i've taken a break
okay you're taking a break
please don't feel obligated to answer
this and if you want us to take this off
we can definitely do so
but how are you making a living nowadays
if you're focusing primarily on the dao
that's always a question i have for
people who focus primarily on the dawah
sure sure so uh
iknow approached me islamic circle of
north
america saying that you know dr sebel
you have passion for dawa for many many
years
why don't you come and join us so they
have a dhawa committee or dhaba
department why don't you come and join
us
and uh they gave me an offer uh
obviously you know you make only a
fraction of what you make up there
but one life to live
you know
i don't want to regret on the day of
judgment
that why didn't i do full-time dawah
when there was an opportunity definitely
i don't want to regret on my deathbed
why didn't i do all of these things that
allah has given me the opportunity the
ability when when there is such a
humongous need
so alhamdulillah with those thoughts in
my mind it was not as hard a decision
as
it could have been
that's proper
i'm the brothers you know that's
probably not
so i mean i mean
if we would go on amazon we could find
that book that you were talking about
right the choice
you should be able to yeah yeah you
should be able to
uh just type
on amazon
you should be able to find it inshallah
yes
inshallah i'm not headed to the list
yeah i'm add to this too now
okay so it is made up of small booklets
yeah on different topic you know
crucifixion or son of god of muhammad
ali
quran the miracle of miracles so he
wrote like maybe 10 15 20 different
booklets and this is like a compilation
of all of them
so you may be able to find those
booklets individually if you search
online pdf copies maybe amazon too but
definitely you should be able to find
also the book the choice inshallah
you said it's a compilation but is there
like a little extra like does he have uh
does he add his own little
extra commentary on that
it may be something new i mean it's kind
of repackaging of the booklets that he
wrote
so if you get whole of the book the
choice i think that will kind of take
care of his other you know items that he
compiled for many many decades
definitely get it inshallah plus he has
so many videos online so watch them but
don't just watch passively write notes
make use of the notes teach other people
that's how you can retain the material
the longer
inshallah yeah i got a lot of questions
on how so
let me start man
the first main question i have is i've
seen some crazy videos on your channel
right there were a lot of people that
come at you a little confrontational and
you are the epitome of stoicism you're
very controlled calm and you try to
always defuse the situation and not you
know
let that person stay emotional
so how do you stay grounded what is what
benefits do you see in that
and why do you think that
a lot of people today are a little too
hard-headed they're a little too
passionate about dawa at the expense of
their roundedness
yes alhamdulillah
you know anything that we do any
interaction that we have
it's important that we need to follow
the example of prophet muhammad
you know as the quran says in surah 33
ayah number 21
the translation is in the person of
muhammad peace be upon him we have the
best example to follow
for those who believe in allah and the
last day and remembers allah much
so always we need to
we need to
have the frame of reference the noble
life of prophet muhammad
so when i'm
when i'm managing a dawah booth for
example or on the street or in the open
house taking the questions i always keep
in mind that how would the prophet
behaves of the lawless if he were in
that situation
so you may have seen a video of mine in
that big guy coming at me any one of you
yeah
that's right when uh fayette had
mentioned that i looked at you and i was
like
i know i've seen you
i know i've seen you it's the guy who
was talking about christianity
and he was like yelling he was just real
obscene but you were just talking about
the entire time yeah
yeah yeah so
two years ago i mean not last year
because there was no convention there
was a ikna convention in baltimore i
believe no washington dc baltimore yeah
dc
and i was walking from the hotel
to the main convention hall with my
family
and as i was on the sidewalk i saw this
big guy with maybe five six other people
holding signs against islam against the
hijab against the muslims all this you
know
you know really nasty signs up there and
he was verbally attacking
the girls the women the muslims in
general
so that's where that's when the video
starts
i'm here then he's up there abusing
someone then i walk up to him and then
he really starts to abuse me saying you
know what do you want
so at that at that uh you know uh point
in time
i was thinking to myself
allah subhanahu talaha has sent this
person
in front of the muslim convention so we
muslims can share the message of islam
to him
see emotionally i could have thought you
know what man this person is abusing
he's making a mess and you know he's
like
creating a scene over here
let me shout him out
i could have done that
i mean those are like the instincts that
all of us have right come on why is he
abusing our people
but then if allah sent him over here
that whole scene was planted in front of
us that allah wants him to learn islam
from me and from the people around
me
not only him but all the his you know
his team members
so that was my you know frame of mind
second second thing is
you know from the psychological point of
view i realize in the first few seconds
you know i mean he's coming at me no
matter what i'm saying and doing
so i was thinking okay fine he may be
like you know six feet tall and 300
pounds compared to 100 pound of me you
know five feet
so i was thinking
psychologically that person is like a
toddler in front of my eyes
i'm not going to yell at a toddler
i'm not going to reason logically with
the toddler i would like to with a smile
with a handshake i would like to calm
the toddler down
i want to listen i want to be a good
listener and then you know nicely calmly
with compassion with empathy let me calm
him down
so those were the things
rushing in my mind to that person when i
was interacting with him and to any
person that i interact so that's what
i would say
should be always our frame of reference
the pope the prophet's noble character
alhamdulillah
so that raises another question
because you've had a fair amount of your
your fair share of experiences in the
taoisean street dawa dealing with
islamophobes or just people that are
uninformed ignorant
what are some common things you notice
today that the average muslim that is
trying to give dawah should be well
informed and educated to refute or at
least educate on for example one example
would be on let's say the age of
which is a very common thing that people
get so what are some some common things
you believe that we should be educated
on
sure sure
so there are two things when it comes to
dawah
well there are many things actually
first and foremost we need to realize
that uh who the person that we are
speaking to you know their background
their culture their race their uh you
know what faith that they belong to or
no faith
so taking that into account that's how
we can package the message the message
of tawheed is always there but how do
you package that message of tawheed
based upon the audience that that you're
interacting with
and i can give you one example inshallah
in the year 627 a delegation of najiran
came to the prophet's masjid
and they wanted to have a conversation
with the prophet and the prophet invited
them in
and these christians they have a three
days and three nights interaction with
the prophet in the masjid nagawi
you guys may have heard about right from
the serum
so they are coming from a trinitarian
background they believe in trinity and
jesus to be god and son of god
so in their interactions
they ask the prophet this important
question so what do you believe about
god
what is your concept of god at that
point the prophet remained silent
and then the wahi came that became
allah
so remember they are coming from a
trinitarian background allah is
packaging the message of oneness of
allah based upon the audience
say he is allah one and only right not
three not multiple persons
then he is eternal he is needed by all
they say jesus to be eternal
along with the father and the holy
spirit it's allah is saying that only
god is eternal no one else and he is the
one who has the attributes of being a
sustainer to you know
all of the creation
then he begets not nor he's begotten
again they're coming from that
background that jesus is the begotten
son of god and then there is no one like
unto god
because they give the attributes of the
creator
to the holy spirit and to jesus peace be
upon him allah is saying that there is
no one like unto him
so allah himself is packaging the
message
so my advice to all of us is we need to
know the audience so we need to package
the message number one
number two is important knowledge
so knowledge of islam is important that
how do we explain the faith of islam
in 30 seconds for example right like a
really quick short you know
bites audiobytes as we say
so in that aspect i have developed a
acronym some of you may have seen it's
omg high
are you guys aware of that
no so suppose if i'm at a dawa booth if
a person asks me the question about
islam and they say you know what i have
30 seconds right or 5 minutes for
example tell me what islam is
so i think in my mind omg all right
it's not oh my god by the way o stands
for oneness of god
i speak to the person that allah exists
and these are his attributes
and by the love and the mercy and the
guidance for the creation allah
appointed
m stands for messengers and prophets
right om
then i go then i go over a list of the
messengers and prophets saying to that
person that all of them they came with
one faith that is to invite people to
the submission of one creator
then i mentioned the names of the
prophets and the messengers a prominent
one including jesus peace be upon him
and the last one prophet muhammad sallam
and
so what do you guys think g may stand
for o is the oneness of allah and for
the messengers
g would be for what
you got me i don't know guidance
you got it masha allah guidance
guidance right so guidance humanity
needs guidance individuals and families
we need guidance so allah has sent
guidance many times in history through
messengers and prophets and the last
time he sent guidance what's through
muhammad sallallahu alaihi
and that guidance is in the quran and
through the example of the prophet peace
be upon him right omg then hi h i
h stands for the hereafter
so we give the analogy that when we go
to school there is accountability based
upon our
our attendance policy
the participation the quizzes the
assignments the final exam based upon
all of these the the teacher the
professor
gives us a grade at the end of the
semester in the same way we will stand
in front of the creator and he will
be examining our life how did we live
this life the beliefs we held
we had and the deeds that we have done
so based on that allah would choose
people's going to paradise and we hope
and pray all of us
and some people into hell fire
and we seeks allah's protection against
it right so that's omgh
what do you think i may stand for right
omg hi
what do you think i may be for
invite
masha allah invite
the person may be thinking you know what
oh makes sense that come on god cannot
be a trinity how can god be up there and
down here and dying god does not die oh
makes sense and makes sense
consistency of the same faith that all
the prophet's messengers came guidance
has to be there it has to be preserved
the there has to be accountability here
after then the person may be thinking
what should i do next that's when you
actively invite the person
so i would say a die in the field should
be able to explain the message of islam
and package it
and last but not the least there should
be some common questions the people may
be having out there
so
the person should be
able to have a list of questions and
practice the questions and know the
references
and repackage the answers based upon the
person
if i'm speaking to an african-american
brother for example i would emphasize so
much on the equality of humanity
of all the races i will mention to him
the sure
number 13 and the wonderful way that the
prophet empowered uh the people of color
at you know
in his time i would go over the
wonderful narrations from the prophet
and how islam
empowered the freed slaves and how they
retain the position you know of high
prominence in in the society
so i would say
racism is one topic lgbt is important
sunisha almost always comes in in the
open houses
age of aisha is yellow
polygamy polyandry yes
why cannot
a lady have four husbands
also the topic of how committed is
allowed for a muslim male to me that
they can marry a jewish or a christian
females
but how can the muslim lady cannot marry
anyone outside the faith of islam right
jihad i think sharia again because of
what's going on in uh you know
in the far east taliban in afghanistan
people would be asking the question
about sharia so i would say that these
are some of the minimal uh topics that i
should be aware of however
some of you listening may be thinking
you know dr sabil this is so
overwhelming
let me go back to my computer to my
books and to my you know kindle let me
read and gain knowledge i would say hold
on
prophet muhammad sallam he said
convey from me even if it is one single
ayah so continue with watching the
videos and taking the notes and
consulting with the scholars but
parallelly go and go in the field and
start conveying the message
even if you know
allah muhammad rasulullah still convey
that if people come and ask you the
questions if you don't know the answers
go and ask people who are in the field
people of knowledge and experience
consult the books and the scholars but
that should not stop you from being in
the field
conveying the message because what i
have seen is
suppose if i'm in the dhawa booth and a
person is interacting with me
after the interaction the self analysis
that i would be doing is one of the most
precious time in dawa because i may be
thinking at that time
you know what i should have smiled more
at that person i should not have
interrupted the person as much as i did
maybe this reference is this analogy i
should have brought maybe i should not
have you know overwhelmed the person
with too much knowledge so that self
analysis can only happen when you're in
the field
not when you're behind the computer
so i would say that these are some of
the ways inshallah a new brother a new
sister a new daii can keep in mind so we
can be effective and god could accept it
in short
inshallah inshallah there's a there's a
pdf like a quick little article that dr
zakir naik published and it just has a
list of like the very most common i'm
sure you might have heard about it the
most common misconceptions that you know
those attacking islam have and it's just
easy to identify those so i'll remember
to put that in the description inshallah
so anyone watching can take a look at
that
yes yes
also i recently wrote a book brothers it
is called the top 50 projects
the top 50 dawah projects that muslims
can do
because many a times our
so so the reason i wrote this book is
for two reasons
reason number one is many a times our
dhawa is out in the clouds up there the
reason we should do it the importance
the necessity but not too many people
speaks about the practicality of dawah
you know suppose if you want to convey
the message to your neighbors
what what is uh required what is the
process how do you break the eyes
if you want to do a masjid open house so
i compiled the top 50 dawah projects
so this is on amazon with my name sabir
ahmad in the top 50 dhawa projects right
now it's in the kindle books hardcopy is
coming out to inshallah
the second reason i wrote this book and
i want to
and i want to
you know make people aware about the
about the methodology of the book is
unfortunately nowadays the dawah has
become like a shouting match
our youth unfortunately when they see
people at the speaker's corner or some
people in the usa or some other places
they may be thinking that dawah is the
they may be thinking that the default
dawah is debate
the defeating the person and shouting
down the person and you know yelling at
the person and the crowd behind you and
then you upload the video on the youtube
so that unfortunately has become the
default state of dawah debate should be
an exception the default state of dawah
should be with a smile with compassion
understanding the person breaking bread
with the person inviting the person
right winning their hearts and minds
that should be the default
state of dawah the prophetic example
so that is the reason i
wrote this book to bring people back
again to the prophetic way of conveying
the message of islam using many many
platforms
subhanallah all right i'm going to put
the link in the description do you know
message me on what's up with the link
and i will you know put it down below
any of you guys that are interested
please check that book out and once you
do leave it a good review if you really
liked it
what's on your mind
i don't know i'm just i'm just thinking
about my experience in the dawah and and
you know all the places i you know could
have implemented these tips and
especially afterwards the
self-reflection the thinking about it um
actually i've mentioned i think once or
twice um
the uh the method the
brother ahmad mentioned or brothers
mentioned is that you know what would
the process do ask that question and
think about it because
that and remembering allah being
conscious of allah those are the two
ways that you know you you shouldn't go
wrong because if you're conscious of
these things you're you're actively
thinking what is the best possible thing
i can do the most emotionally
intelligent thing i can do uh something
that you know is not going to get me a
sin right uh in the eyes of allah
and often time when you ask that way or
ask these questions you act in a way
which is best in the end
so even if the person is is yelling at
you and screaming at you and all this
stuff
most people most normal people nowadays
right and it doesn't mean it's good but
most normal people nowadays are going to
yell back
but it's not just the person you're
giving dawa to it's everyone witnessing
it right because if people see that this
person is yelling at you and that you're
being calm and patient right like
professor krause and hamza zortzis we
saw the difference in character people
are more more likely to incline towards
the muslim who's calm than like the
non-muslim who's yelling and screaming
just because of that difference in
character
so it's it doesn't just have an impact
on on you and the person you're giving
dawah to but every single individual who
witnesses it
uh you know it also affects them as well
so subhanallah
all this is just making me reflect on
you know myself whether it's online or
in person and places i could have done
better places where i was a little too
you know pushy a little too firm like so
why aren't you a muslim you know what i
mean
so we always need to like keep on
calibrating ourselves yeah because many
a times in the heat of the situation the
you know emotions may oh
may overpower us
so it's important to remind ourselves
you know in that interaction with that
big guy
i was standing here and he was standing
there and there was a lady she was just
watching us
you may have seen then she approached
both of us and she said you know what if
i have to choose a faith i would choose
islam based upon the way that you guys
are asked you know interesting i
literally said that i remember
so what rami is mentioning is exactly
there could be many people watching in
fact the video does not show it but
there were literally you know 50 100
muslims behind me
there were non-muslims walking by there
were many security you know people also
watching and listening
so all of this we need to be aware and
allah is watching obviously right so we
need to be
aware that our dawah interactions what
we say how we say
need to align with the noble example of
prophet muhammad
makes me think too like
dawa isn't just
you know like
what you see on youtube and stuff like
that could just be
you talking up front or like you said
your neighbor or something like that it
could be something so simple
and um
just like romney i'm thinking about it
too because anytime i tell someone about
islam
i get so like oh i
i guess emotional because i'm like so
passionate about it so i just over share
i give them too much
and then after that i'm like oh man i
could have said this
like i think i said too much
and like i don't think i got through
them but at the end of the day like
the self-reflection process is needed
because it allows us to like fine-tune
our delivery
but then at the end of the day it's also
the color of allah like in each
situation whatever we bring is exactly
what allah wanted us to bring so
yeah man so always try to get feedback
from other people
you know like other muslims
um like a really critical feedback by
the way you know what this is my video
can you watch it and give some feedback
so that could be one way besides
self-analysis second second base you
know as you have mentioned
dawah doesn't have to wait until you go
to the speaker's corner for example on
the weekend
dawa is a state of mind that means every
occasion with any non-muslim anywhere
any environment can become a place for
dhawa that can be in the plane and you
may have seen some of the videos of mine
i have most of my interesting encounters
they were on the plane
so it doesn't matter in the plane you're
or you are standing for the bus on the
bus station
you are you know in the supermarket for
example doing groceries
uh in the bank with the bank clerk so
any place can be a state of dawa with
the neighbors for example so dawa is a
is a state of mind so we need to create
opportunities for dawa and not just wait
for them to happen
yeah i think dawa in our actions is also
very important or
i think one of the most important ways
too
because like think about it like yeah
mentally we might be thinking all that
and we might be
uh
you know insha'allah we might be ready
for those situations
when someone says something or someone
does something and say ah perfect
teachable moment you know where we can
give dawah but it's like even when
there's nothing being done like just our
actions like how you spoke to that guy
and the lady came up to you and was like
just based on like
how you guys are interacting
if i had to choose a faith i would
choose islam
like just
i don't know me personally like i'll
walk around
and i have a very just like kind of
straight face
uh i'm i only smile if i'm like
if i want to smile or like if something
causes me to smile or laugh i want to
laugh or something but it's like i
always look back and i'm like
why why don't i just enjoy myself more
why don't i just walk around with a
smile on my face and
just greeting people with that love i
mean the prophet sallallahu alaihi was
someone even said that smiling is is a
form of charity
you know so it's like
too much too often times we get too
wrapped up here and forget that our
actions is a is an unspoken language
and that if if we can
capitalize on that then we can
capitalize on a huge part of davo
so to the initial question of uh you
know fiat but you mentioned this
i would have i would say there would be
three components of dawa right time is
short i'm not going to elaborate on it
one is knowledge
second is how do you package the
knowledge
and thirdly the the invitation part of
it
so dawa is actually invitation it's not
just knowledge it's not just passing on
the brochure for example it's also
actively inviting the person i mean
obviously how do you invite it we can
discuss it later but
knowledge how do you package it so when
it comes to the packaging of the
knowledge
my encouragement to all three of you
myself and for every day out there is
that we should be taking some formal
classes
how do we become competent speakers
competent communicators
if you are with one person compared to
many people in a dawa booth or a masjid
open house so each single muslim should
be an excellent speaker an eloquent
speaker should be able to articulate
so there are so many research so i also
take classes by the way just to let you
know guys right
because how do you package the message
is equally important so not just the
knowledge that you have but how do you
deliver that knowledge both of them are
equally important
so that's my request not just to three
of you but every listener who is here so
one place where i go to to take classes
is called the toastmasters.com
you may have heard about it they train
speakers or they train people how to be
competent speakers for example
toastmasters.com
i've heard about them they have groups
in every city more or less
yes yes even madina they have groups
when i went to the caribbean south
america they have groups
bottom line is we are the most
resourceful society in the history of
humanity
so there is no excuse for us that you
know i don't have time i mean
to go and learn time management
if you're not a good project manager
take some classes the resources read the
books watch the videos
so there are so many resources out there
a ideal muslim and ideal guy should not
only have passion
and be a good speaker but should be a
good time manager should have you know
good communication skills project
management skills good people skills
all of these things are so needed and
they are readily available for all of us
so i would say all of these coming
together will make the person
and the act of da'wah effective and we
pray to allah that he accept it
i mean
i'm in europe i mean are they just in
time for the end
okay no more questions then
uh inshaallah allah look forward to
episode 2 insha allah because i do have
more questions
for coming on uh time is limited so
without further ado maybe we should send
it
okay and i pray that mashallah your
brothers you know instead of just
playing video games somewhere and have a
video game channel you know cod and
whatnot you are here
mashallah giving your time your
investment your your you know your
ability that allah has given you may
allah put burka in your channel
in your effort
and
purify your intentions and help more
people inshallah to see the beauty of
islam and with allah's guidance
inshallah they can also realize that
islam is the truth
so jazakallahu khan for inviting me
assalamu alaikum with allah
walking
to end this lovely episode with the
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um